-Let's get to the news.
Christmas is less
than one week away.
And then it's right back to
the attic for Michael Bublé.
[ Laughter ]
According to CNN,
President Trump
is leading the push
for a full and rapid withdrawal
of U.S. troops from Syria.
Apparently he just found out
that Syria does not share
a border with Mexico.
[ Laughter ]
CNN has obtained new documents
showing that President Trump
signed a letter of intent to
move forward with negotiations
to build a Trump Tower
in Russia,
despite his attorney
Rudy Giuliani
claiming that the document
was never signed.
Said Giuliani,
"That's not Trump's signature.
The document was clearly
signed by someone named
Aye yai yai aye yai yai yai!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Senate majority leader
Mitch McConnell today
introduced a bill to fund the
government through February 8th.
Apparently there was
a lot of concern
about government employees
being left in a lurch
over the holidays.
And what happened then?
Well, in Whoville, they say,
McConnell's neck grew
three sizes that day.
[ Slide whistle ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Google has unveiled its list
of the most searched celebrities
of 2018,
with Demi Lovato
topping the list,
narrowly beating out the second
most searched-for celebrity,
someone to host the Oscars.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right.
Google has unveiled its list
of the most searched-for
celebrities in 2018.
And for the 81st year in a row,
it's Amelia Earhart.
[ Light laughter ]
Yeah. Yeah, that's about
what I expected.
[ Laughter ]
The New York state
attorney general's office
has issued a report claiming
that over one quarter
of all seafood in grocery stores
is mislabeled.
Don't believe me?
Check out this sushi.
[ Laughter ]
Police in Iowa were called on
a gym teacher this week
after she showed up
to work so drunk
that she had red, watery eyes
and smelled of alcohol.
Sounds like alcoholism was
the one ball she couldn't dodge.
[ Audience ohs ]
You guys, it's Christmas.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I'm worried about
these next few.
[ Laughter ]
I'm excited and worried.
A restaurant in Japan has
started selling a new line of
girls' hair-flavored
fried chicken.
[ Audience ohs ]
And now, we wait.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"We see you ordered the chicken.
Take a seat."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
A restaurant in Japan has
started a new line of
girls' hair-flavored
fried chicken.
That story again.
A restaurant in Japan
stopped using hair nets.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Can't figure you guys out.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, Scottish Parliament
yesterday
officially changed the name of
gingerbread men
to gingerbread people.
And if you like that,
you'll love person fingers.